Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa
Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa B Moy, mooy, mooy, mooy, mooy, mooy,
mooy, mooy, mooy, mooy, mooy, mooy.
Mooy, booy, boon!
Mooy, mooy, boon.
Sound good?
Cool.
We're playing Ratcoin today.
Might be a bit of a shorter stream.
I just wanted to stream.
This is my travel setup.
I apologize for any scuff.
is too much moe possible absolutely not moe is justice hello
minky hello hello but i saw this and i was like i saw it
like on the steam page and i was like coin pusher roguelike
i know nothing about it i just thought it sounded cute oh
that was windows virus and threat protection.
Ignore it.
Minto is very moy, moy, moy, moy.
Today?
I'm moy, moy, moy.
Every day.
Maybe.
The song is kind of a bop there.
Hey, happy, happy birthday.
Ooh, do, ooh, ooh, beep.
Did you guys play these coin pusher games?
I'll be honest.
I didn't really.
What did I spend...
What did I play at the arcade?
As a wee little ghost.
What did I play?
I don't remember.
You hated these as a kid?
You got a free iPod from it, no way.
Wait, I thought it was a scam.
Right?
Someone else said it felt like a scam.
I thought so too.
Moy, Moy, Minky Rock Queen Cat.
no time the crap you do the crime you do the rap coin time
whack-a-mole okay i don't want to like toot my own horn or
anything but i was a mean green whack-a-mole machine i was
all over that oh yeah i'm all
One day I'll show you my skills, my prowess of the
whack-a-mole.
Rarely play these IRL kind of scammy.
One, one, I remember one, one, one, one machine that I also
really like to play is the one that has the light that spins
around.
And then you slam the button and it has to stop on the
jackpot.
That is a scam.
That one is a scam.
Boy pushers were always the ones that would win pennies.
They're all a scam and that they won't pay out prizes unless
they've earned more than they're worth.
Yeah, those ones are rigged.
Hi, Mintonio.
But as a kid, I don't even know...
I didn't know that word.
I didn't know what rigged meant.
I was...
I was just a ye...
A we- oh, a yee?
I was a wee, you know, freshly dead ghost.
And I was like, surely the afterlife would not be so cruel
to rig things and scam you.
Ye old.
The previous player might have paid it off though.
Yeah, exactly!
It's literally the meme of the guy mining, you know?
A ye little wisp.
Yeah.
A we?
We you?
Hmm.
But yeah.
For those types of like ticket games, I also did basketball
game.
I liked that one.
That one is just skill though.
go thank you so much for the fun get there thank you yeah
those the basketball oh and ski ball oh my gosh ski ball
baby yeah i love ski ball and then um um for things that
wouldn't give me tickets i was all over ddr but now it's my
chance to try the coin pusher and it's a is a roguelike so
i'm very interested in how it will go
oh my god ski ball is so fun it has no reason being that fun
yeah it's also not a scam but the only thing they could scam
you out of is if you if they like lower the ticket output
you know what i mean baby core thank you so much for the
program the machine to give you half the tickets that it
would normally or but let's try it let's play the game let's
check it out watch this why what is it what if this is like
actually when i bought this game there was like some bundles
with uh there was a bundle with um oh my gosh what was
Same dev maybe, but maybe same publisher?
Ski ball sounds like something you do on a cruise?
Why?
Oh, because you're skiing?
I want to go on...
I've never wanted to go on a cruise before, but there's a
Disney cruise that has a roller coaster on it.
I must go as a roller coaster connoisseur.
I hit the RKs.
I give the illusion of something.
skill when it's rigged in RNG.
No, I get it.
I get it.
That's like the one where the light spins around and you hit
it.
You know?
That's how I feel about that.
Okay.
Cardboard cabinet.
15 rounds are flagship cabinet.
Owner teaches you how to play the game.
Start the tutorial.
Oh, look at this.
There's other characters.
Biologist.
Wait.
Oh, no wait.
Okay, so you can get other characters and then you unlock?
There's a lot to unlock.
Wow, okay.
Biologist, chemist, trader, astronomer, a big eater.
Cute, but let's do the owner.
Let's do the tutorial.
A tutorial for beginners.
Okay, we play.
Did it get louder?
Welcome, I'm testing this coin pusher machine.
It's built from scrap parts.
It looks rough, but it's fully functional.
Inserted copper coins come out of these pink shoots.
Oh, a coin inserted slides to the other side.
Want to try?
It's much more funny when you play it yourself.
Oh, okay, Q and E.
It's a Gamba game.
Gamba game?
Oh, and it's Tiny Minto.
Shh.
We can't say that.
We can't say the G word.
Otherwise, YouTube, Madam YouTube will scold me.
Wait, what?
Oh.
The G word?
Don't say it.
Don't spray it.
Once a coin drops into the scoring zone, it's scored and
will give you a score and I think those are green tickets.
Shows how many green tickets you have.
Gasp.
Don't kill me.
I'm already dead.
A coin score... I should pay attention, huh?
This is a tutorial.
A coin score equals coin value.
Score rate.
Now reach the target score to clear this round.
too fast or too slow you can use these buttons to adjust the
speed oh whoops ran out of coins here's ten more for you
keep this a secret wait what are these oh they show you
how's the audio by the way I feel like it's kind of loud
especially that part where it's give me a second I'm gonna
lower it just a bit let's enter the shop there's a shop
already enter the shop oh it was good just kidding here i'll
just i'll i'll do middle there we go okay oh oh i'm pressing
things that i'm not meaning to press one second
wait oh sorry my setup is all like all over the place right
now okay there we go after each round you can spend the
tickets to buy items and the shop oh we can buy like
different a cool clip expansion bad coin check out our wide
range of special coins each have unique effects you have
enough tickets why not buy them all okay oh wait you said
buy them all purchase coins go into the coin clip but now it
can only hold two then why did you tell me to buy all of
them?
Oh, DVR is on.
Actually, I think DVR is on, and also my stream latency is
kind of high.
I'm sorry, guys.
I just turned off the DVR there.
That was my fault.
I forgot to change it.
So if I'm a little delayed in responding to you guys, it's
because it's normal latency right now.
It's not low latency.
Okay.
Let's expand it.
Oh, this is how you... Okay, you can expand it.
Okay.
And then, what's up to four?
What is this last one?
Bomboying!
Oh, yeah.
I love a girl with some bomboying, bomboying.
Let's start the next round.
You can start with an amount of copper coins at the start of
each round.
Concerning copper coins.
Silver coin!
It's your lucky day!
Let's use up all of our coins in our hand.
Is there a way to...
Is there a strategy?
Surely?
Yeah, I've run out of coin!
Time to exchange for some.
Exchange ticket for coin.
The dots below show how many remaining exchanges you have.
Uh...
Okay, so I have four at the moment.
Now the special coins.
They'll be inserted through the central chute.
Try using all your special coins.
This chute?
Is that what it means?
ZBR off.
She's erasing the pass.
Wait.
Huh?
Wait, I'm...
I'm queuing and I'm eating.
Oh, I have to insert them.
Oh, I see, I see how it works.
Okay, but they do special stuff.
So this one breeds when touching.
Oh, they bred.
Oh, oh, they bred.
Oh, they're breeding on my stream.
And this one on exchange explodes.
Oh.
Uh.
Cool.
Oh, wait.
Do I explode it?
Um.
Nearly, oh, pushes nearby coins away, then it is destroyed.
Okay.
Okay, I think we have to exchange again.
Oh, oh, that's what it means.
Interesting.
I like our little critter friends down here.
They're so fun.
Wait, but I could...
What about these silver coins?
I can keep going.
Maximize my profits.
And what about these?
Oh, it became a weak coin.
Tired bunny.
From all the action.
All the bedroom action, huh?
Wait.
I could keep exchanging.
Let's try and get the silver coins.
Right?
Can I even?
Oh, oh, oh, this one.
We can get this one.
We can get this one for sure.
Actually, I don't know.
Our exchange is over.
It's just...
Ah!
It's not a scam!
Setting up DVR to two times speed.
Today is my birthday, now boycaster, happy birthday!
Thank you so much for this super chat!
Happy birthday!
Buy out all the coins.
Okay.
Killer coin.
Kills nearby bad coin.
Each kill is 20 tickets.
Oh, we got chips.
What are chips?
chips you could buy chips now 40 chance for cool oh wait for
coins to give plus one ticket when scored money bag chips
are equipped on the slot card they give powerful boosts
you're ready for round three this is so fascinating this is
so interesting every three rounds bad coins appear drive out
good ones.
It's a... it's a poroid?
She's got a little...
bald head!
Yeah, you can get passives and stuff.
Interesting.
They restrict you from exchanging for coins.
You'd be better to clear the bad coins, ASAP.
I have an idea.
Try inserting this.
Kill.
Oh, kill.
Perfect.
All the back points have been cleared.
They called him poor.
What is the game?
Game, what are you saying, huh?
Those sound bad.
The monk haircut.
It's like...
What are they trying to say, huh?
That's because this one...
Killer coin kills the bad coins.
The more you understand how coins affect each other, the
more options you'll have.
I understand.
They're saying poor is bad.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so I'm guessing...
Okay, I'm seeing that it, like, doesn't reset the coins.
You just, like, have a new, like...
kind of strategically know when you want to put out a coin
like for example this one oh it's so wait is that oh it's no
it's tired i didn't realize it was tired
okay it's so solution for poor ones laser them
uh everything is in the middle oh nice nice I like wanted to
just explode some stuff like there do
we get more I guess you get more tickets technically if you
don't exchange before the end of your round okay there's
slipping and a slide in it is
strategically exchanging special coins for bonuses yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay it's cuz I guess there's no point in let me
see let me see if I exchange and do some more because our
current is you know what I mean like okay if that will say
and like help us get to the next target you get what i'm
saying you get what i'm saying you get what my shoots are
spitting out
okay i have no clue what's happening on the street on the
screen me neither we're learning this together everybody so
now we're at 201 so if our next target say is like 300 500
even i don't think it I don't know how exponential it raises
but you know what I mean like if it's more will that will
our current help push us to the next target you get what I'm
saying you start from zero for every round oh you do okay
that's what I was testing oh after clearing bad coins you
can pick a keychain one prize slot retain unused well that's
what I was just saying if we retain the unused coins at the
round end is that not good
oh keychains provide bonuses that last the entire run oh
they're forcing me to do the shop coupon let's expand the
coin clip try vertical expansion this time okay what's the
difference oh vertical expansion it adds another layer,
allowing one additional same coin to be stored.
Now you can buy prizes, so it must be activated manually.
Reign three to six of your most purchased coins.
Purchase prizes go straight to prize slots.
Okay.
What is this?
Next coin?
Next regular coin will be silver coin after six coins
inserted.
I don't see why we don't just buy everything, because it's a
tutorial.
You know?
So now, try using the prize rain badge.
Score multiple coins rapidly to create combos.
The higher the combo count, the higher the score rate.
Oh my god, there's so much happening here.
Okay.
Enough combo light up the, wait, enough combo light up the
spin energy bar.
You get one
it.
I'll cut you some slack this time.
25 more coins.
Oh, I see.
They hop towards each other.
That's so cute.
They're breeding.
You have no...
You have... No, nobody.
Here, I'll give you somebody.
Only one.
Okay.
Can we win that travel size Minto in the claw machine?
What do you mean?
Shade, welcome back.
Thank you!
Our combo, our combo is going crazy.
It's not.
Hmm.
What if I do another one?
Oh, oops.
Oh no, he's too far away.
They can't sense each other.
No!
I didn't realize.
Okay, just blow it all to...
Oh.
We got 25 more coins somehow?
How'd that happen?
Look, it's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Alright, we're gonna...
Wait, watch this.
Watch this.
No, hold on.
I want to blow it up.
Blow!
Oh, I have to explode.
I forgot it's not when you launch it, it's when you
exchange.
Fill bar, wheel spin bonuses.
Yeah.
Okay, let's just enter the shop.
What is this a saw coin?
Oh my gosh.
Are you guys going to Sawcoin?
Saw's unmodified coin into four mini coins.
Let's just buy everything.
Starcoin, Astrofall, where Starlands convert nearby regular
coins to silver coins.
When any coin scored, 1% chance to destroy Astrofall.
And more bunny coin.
Let's do...
I only have one slot left, so let's do...
plus two score rate minus 0.3 minus 0.3 per clip expansion
oh and then we got another prize draws in coins in the
selected areas and scores them all oh that sounds pretty
good so these are one time use okay interesting what's saw
coin oh yeah saw coin
What is this one?
25% chance of getting two times.
We'll do that one.
This is the tutorial's final round.
Go crush it.
Can you remove the chips you don't need?
I don't know.
Oh, oops.
I wonder if there's like a good strategy on how to...
I guess if you're like, I need more stuff on this side, you
like push on here.
you know?
Oh!
Wait, I should probably exchange though so I can grab that.
Yeah.
I want to try this one.
Whoa!
And then keep going, keep going, keep going.
Keep destroying, keep destroying.
Yeah, keep destroying.
Keep destroying.
And then...
What does this one do?
Oh my god!
Oh it's Insano mode!
Number go up, number go up!
What the heck is this?
Tax doll.
Well now I'm curious.
Oh, oops, on side.
We want stuff on this side.
Take that round one.
Exactly.
Wait, I can only exchange it.
Oh, wait.
Let's try a...
Relic coin.
When did I get...
Oh, chummy coin.
Where am I getting all these coins from?
Let's just play them all.
Oh, wait.
Also, I have this.
Okay.
Huge stacking coming.
We have more balls.
I only have one more exchange.
Oh, it gives...
of the coin though.
No, it will become a bad coin!
No, on exchange.
Wait, we have no exchange.
Please, keep pushing over here.
I want the ball.
Please!
I guess it doesn't matter though, this is just the tutorial.
Okay, whatever.
I'm just trying to get a feel for the game, you know what I
mean?
great there's the code for you all if you're like dang that
was like a the luckiest seed ever let's play 15 rounds this
does feel very clover pit
okay no more tutorial guys oh and look how cute we have our
little coins and our chippies And our prizes, okay.
Plus two exchange limit.
What does that mean?
Gain 20% of tickets held at the round end.
Ooh.
Master in using math coins.
We need more.
No, you guys, you can't say the G word.
You can't say that.
We have to use the P word.
Push.
We need more pushing games.
Games that will make me push.
Games that will make me want to...
Double down.
Or...
Games that will make me want to...
Hit.
Let's play.
Oh.
Slot card.
Oh, you get a different cart.
What the heck?
We'll just do a green ticket, though.
We play.
All right, team.
This is it.
This is the real deal.
We're going to send all of our coins over this way.
All in on this side.
My comp.
Oh, we already...
Easiest game ever, guys.
Time to push.
Easiest game ever.
We have 20 tickets.
What is that?
Is that a dog?
Strongly shake the cabinet.
Raccoon's paw, we've seen this one.
I think the ticket whip is pretty great.
Marszoin.
Oh, it's Mars coin.
Is that Sheila's dog?
The turtle coin.
Doubles the required combo for spin energy.
Boo!
I like how this one is just the equivalent of kicking the
machine.
Tick coin.
Whits scored get 20 tickets.
What is alt?
Hold on.
Oh, we can pin it.
I think we should at least get two.
When in play.
0.5 score rate per prize ball spawned.
Yeah.
Fallen, thank you.
Hi, Mito.
Hello.
I just got home from work.
Might fall asleep watching.
No worries.
O2.
We're just hanging out.
It's going to be not too long of a stream, probably.
But I'm glad the internet is holding out and everything.
But thank you so much for the summertime!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Let's see.
Let's try the tick coin.
I think getting...
Let's go for, like, a ticket route, right?
Also, plus 15 value per round start.
It's...
These types of games are always so tricky.
when you first start out because like you have to learn all
the games lingo.
You know what I mean?
Like each one of these like puzzly roguelike games are
always like oh yeah the value.
I'm like what's the value of what?
You know like it's so like oh my gosh I have to have a whole
new dictionary for every game.
Maybe it's a value of the base core or value of this coin so
the value of the relic coin goes up plus 15 every round as
my assumption circus of values number go up let's also do
this ticket whip yeah baby and i think we'll save our
tickets we'll save our tickets let's go
noise oh i should probably shoot this though huh come on
tickle
we're gonna get you in there all right we're exchanging okay
oh we have so many exchanges nice go go go bonus coins let's
go oh thank you thank you thank you it all happened at once
I feel like, though, this is going to be not so great when
we need, like, crazy numbers of tickets, you know what I
mean?
Because it doesn't stat, or rather, it doesn't, like, it's
only 20 forever.
It's not so great, right?
Hmm.
Bill, you're not late at all.
I only saw this yesterday.
I thought you would love it.
Yeah!
Me too!
I- well, no, I didn't- I saw it the other day.
I immediately put it on my schedule.
Between you being here, coin clinky noise and shifting into
maximum overdrive to catch up, my dopamine levels won't let
me do math anyway.
All right.
Thank you, resting glitch face out.
We don't need to do math here.
We just need to think about coins.
So close, so close, so close.
I like this because, like, there's almost a bit of strategy
more so than, like, um like with clover pit like it's your
gap like rather don't say the g word you are you are leaving
it up to the fate of the slot but here if i'm like oh i'm
trying to push this coin i can push it like i can send more
coins over this way than you know what i mean wait what is
this one shiny right here something going on there oh i just
realized we totally won the round i didn't notice
Cursive!
Welcome to Babu Ship!
Thank you!
Oh, this one was an initial plus 8 coin.
This one, tax doll.
Plus 2 ticket for each coin in selected area.
Oh, imagine if you have like crazy stacks.
Wallenplay plus 3% coin conversion rate.
Okay.
Chum-ing.
Chum-chum-chum.
Chum-chum-chum, chum-chum, chum-chum, chum-chum, chum-chum,
chum-chum, chum-chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum,
chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum,
chum skill-chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum,
chum, you're- I hope you- I hope you- I hope you get lots of
rest for your eyes.
Take it easy.
Chum-chum-chum, chum-chum.
Chum-chum, chum, chum, chum.
One second.
What the heck?
My hotel room is all messed up.
That's so funny.
Grambling.
It rhymes with grambling.
Wait, it's grambling without the R.
Is there two R's and grambling?
Wait, G-R-A-M-E-L-I-N-G.
Grambling.
I'm at the spelling bee.
Can you use it in a sentence?
Grambling is the forbidden YouTube word plus an R.
Okay, I have to decide.
Um, we don't want you to corrupt into a bad question.
coin let's try this one this one this clover oin sound
interesting and then maybe money oh wait i wonder if i can
get rid of these once i okay it doesn't seem like it so if
you have a chip you are stuck with said chip oh wait no you
can sell it just kidding it says you can sell okay that's
good plus two score rate
How do, but it says minus 0.3 per clip expansion.
If I expand my clip.
So the sparrow can not grow per more than two?
Minto is rambling while the coins are clanking.
Rip the VOD.
Let's see.
I do want to try another special coin, though.
Oh, chummy coins.
Chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum.
In the cabinet or in the...
Oh, wall in the clip two counts.
What if we go with a chum?
A chum.
Chum chips.
Chum, chum meta.
Chum chip meta.
This ain't no chump change.
This is the chum meta.
I don't know.
I'm just...
We're just going.
Wait, I got turtles.
Oh no, no!
Okay, we keep...
This, or we dump this one.
This one stays in the clip, maybe.
We gotta get rid of these toytles.
Toytle, toytle, toytle, toytle.
Remember when it was timestamped where you were making baby
noises that you did?
Oh!
Yeah, I can't make baby noises.
I was like, And...
And YouTube thought I was telling the children to buy loot
boxes or something.
They were like, you can't do that!
You can't do that!
We're gonna get these guys out of here.
We need more
chummy-chum-chum-chummy-chummy-chummy-chummy-chummy coin.
What is this one?
Oh, a silver coin.
Okay, we're exchanging.
Come on.
That was such a bad play.
I ruined it.
I ruined it all for exchanging.
There we go.
Oh, I got another one.
Oh, nice!
Nice, nice!
We're so close to getting rid of one toital.
Okay, watch this.
Watch this.
It's going to happen.
okay watch this into the they have such long tails gooo gooo
gooo gamut no you guys are trying to
now some of these coins like the one that I just spent is it
worth it you know what I mean like oh good we got rid of
them is it worth playing or Like, should I keep them?
I think there's, like, some coins you want to keep in the
clip.
It seems like.
Because if they're not in play...
I don't know.
I'm still learning.
Rocky, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
We're pushing, we're pushing.
I'm pushing my limits.
White hole doll.
Draws in coins in selected areas and transports them back to
the upper platform.
at their oh the bank sounds good let's get the bank this is
at the end of the round you gain plus one ticket per coin in
hand seems to be a lot to this game right a little bit it's
it's definitely more um i mean oh these saves the games are
always strategy don't get me wrong but there's on here then
yeah there is a lot to the game but for now we get more chum
oh wait i probably have to buy vertical
because then we can get more chum
tick coin yeah so many mechanics we're gonna i'm gonna not
play this for a while and then other people will play it and
then once i come back people know all the crazy strategies
and They'll be like, they'll be like, you were right, Minto!
Chummy coin!
Chum, chum, chum it up!
It's the meta!
Everybody chums, everybody chums!
We're chums, right guys?
We're chums?
I too went to be pushed into the abyss for tickets.
Some people get copyright striked by themselves for using
their own songs.
Oh, didn't that happen to Oli the other day?
Crazy Oli?
I think that happened to her.
I am going to expand as well.
We don't have the one that...
Screw it.
Let's do all of them.
Let's get all of it.
Alright, let's go.
Wait.
Have people, baby.
Oh, yeah!
Screw you, turtle.
Screw you.
Oh, and Bale did too.
Oh, no!
I had no idea.
Wait.
Win and play Hooray
Soundtrack is Nice pop
It sucks that This one actually no this is good The fact
that it's kind of stuck in here Just kidding I lied It's
kind of a good thing Greater coin Also I should play Or no
We'll keep collecting the chums We'll keep collecting chums
Okay Cyclotic!
Welcome back, thank you!
Alright, we only have one toital.
Two toital.
Oh, whoops.
Get the multipliers first.
Oh yeah, I forgot!
We got the sucky!
Hmm.
We should probably do one.
There we go.
Right, right in here.
Wait, but I want this to stay in play, right?
Hmm.
This is a lot to learn.
This is a lot to learn, huh?
Get the title!
We're exchanging again.
No, none of them fail!
Yeah, very bolotro-coded.
Wait, I just realized the coins are getting like Obliterated
do you see this wait wait a second They're They're not even
like getting that this is up Is this not like a grinder?
Okay, I should push some more.
Yeah, there we go.
Oh, yeah Oh, yeah, all right.
I can't exchange much more it's okay though this is this is
just how it happens coin murder yeah we need more down there
oh oh that was my last one my last coin oh we're so close oh
my gosh we're so close to getting it
Okay.
Our last exchange, everybody.
If we die, we die.
Maybe.
Kill the turtles!
Uh-oh.
Uh, maybe I can push from this side.
How do you know when to give- oh.
It tells you when to give up.
How are you supposed to give value out of coins if the
machine destroys them?
That's a great question.
Only one time for each run.
Done.
Okay.
That wasn't so great you got- Oh wait, I could have used my
doll, but that's fine.
Obtain a random coin.
That's fine.
this one half coin consumes half ticket balance plus 10
value per wait consumes half ticket ticket balance and plus
10 value per ticket consumed cool oh so it like it giveth
and it taketh speaker on plus three tickets to sale price of
all coins and clip per new coin it touches I just realized
you're saying kill the turtles and throw them into the
shredders the TMNT code wait you're so right you're so right
let's buy this clover one again if I'm using if I'm reading
it correctly oh destroys the bad coins oh but this is not we
can hold on to it we can hold on to it
Does this stack?
At round start.
Oh!
I misinterpreted this.
TMNT mentioned?
Cowabunga!
I'm spitting all over the place.
Oh!
I just dropped the cap to my water.
it's okay we're learning we're learning we're learning
there's a lot of coins oh bonus time why i mean i'm not
gonna complain but our target is 800
okay so if i i see the thing about shooting them in the
middle like that is they just don't they just on top of each
other they they don't fall as easily you know what i mean oh
what's wrong way actually maybe it's fine if we do it here
again though we're trying to get this guy oh my god he's so
tanky as far as my birthday go boy happy early birthday
happy early birthday don't shoot as quickly and they won't
stack okay okay okay let's try it again
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I should play that.
Oh!
Nice.
I...
I think...
Wow, that was, like, so pathetic.
The bonus time!
It was so pathetic.
Stocking can be good.
if you got a good way to push them all yeah i'm struggling
to i'm just gonna see how this works you know what i mean
drawing coins and select areas and transfers them
i'm struggling to like 800 coins we're only at 300 you know
we really have to use i think this game relies heavy on
combo it seems.
I think combos are a huge part of maybe?
Hmm.
Combos and multipliers.
I mean, yeah.
I guess that's just kind of how any roguelike is, but maybe
I'm struggling with like the getting there, you know?
Maybe chum is difficult this early on.
Yeah, dropping a lot of coins at once and getting like big,
big...
I guess at this point it is like more of a...
Let's come on, more combo, more combo, please.
No, I'm gonna lose it!
Come on, more combo!
More combo!
Yeah, yeah, more combo!
Oh, oh, oh!
What did I get?
Oh, a coin.
Thank you.
Hmm.
But still, I have two exchange and we're barely halfway
there.
I have to play faster for a combo.
Okay, so maybe I am taking it a little slow, right?
It's okay.
This is like our first...
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I got a mystery!
what is this oh my god a stinking ball wait please no
I'm out of coins
feels more RNG heavy than something like Bilatro yes or no
the toy idols you have to spend a bunch of tickets and
almost no items you have to spend some to earn some yeah
okay we got an achievement we got a pity achievement and a
greater coin on exchange cores other nearby coins with
higher value oh oh i just saw how much we need i have 300
If I retry, I don't know if it shouldn't do the same seed,
right?
So we'll just go to the menu and play a new one.
Math coins.
Okay, so let's also look towards math coins.
Oh, okay.
Craziness.
Come on.
One thing I don't like is...
when I hover over I don't like how this takes over the whole
screen.
It's like a lot.
Alright, enter the shop.
Let's see what we got.
Denton, it's all prize balls.
On exchange.
25% of getting 2 times.
Okay, let's not go for the bank.
We're growing.
On exchange.
Three rounds later.
Corrupts.
Profiteeroyne.
Plus 20% shop prices while in play.
We are welcome back!
Okay.
Yeah, there's a lot happening on the screen.
We are...
Getting our...
We are making our way through.
We'll keep doing these and hope that we get money from them.
I guess so.
Oh, I did it again.
Where I just kind of stacked them.
There we go.
Oops.
All right, exchange.
Come on, give me that silver.
Give me that sweet, sweet silver.
There she goes!
okay okay deceptively complex yeah it really is it really is
if i am all for um if you guys want to help out if you're
like oh like i understand math coin value let's which one is
this is our math which one is our math coin
we got some good stuff going on here i think in Add number
of coin in here.
Start of the round.
Math coin.
Right now, math coins are good for us.
Like, the chummy coin is a math coin.
What are the pros and cons of DVR versus no DVR on YouTube?
Oh, that's a great question, Malcolm.
Basically,
DVR helps well no rather a lot of streamers do no dvr
because you know if when i'm reading chat when i'm very
active with reading chat sometimes people will not be um at
the same point of the live stream as everyone else but
they'll still be chatting they don't realize they're behind
you know and so like like they're chatting but they'll be
like you know a couple minutes behind or something because
sometimes YouTube, it depends on your internet as well.
And so sometimes it will just like do that.
And then also sometimes people will do it like, for example,
maybe they are streaming and they accidentally desktop
capture and a little whoopsie shows and something like that.
And it helps so that people can't go back and like
screenshot it people can um you know they could go back and
uh clip that out if they need to
so it makes me feel so awkward it's it's like i wish i could
do it for like story-based games you know because obviously
if someone comes in and it's just like i have no idea what's
going on i'm so confused i wish i could just go back five
minutes and see what i missed you know things like that but
it's so unreliable because some people some people's
internets will be slower faster and so they'll get off sync
yeah
I sent a message not knowing it was 10 minutes behind once
and I felt embarrassed don't be embarrassed I get it though
wait we're getting this bad coin oh this is the shop prices
okay maybe we want the bunny oh wait we have to expand
though if we want that
I wish I could see what this coin is that it turns into.
We could re-roll.
Tick coin.
Let's just get this for now.
Oh wait, my clip is full, that's right.
Um...
Not perfect, but it works if you want to protect your
privacy.
Now, uh...
Hit Alt and you can check.
But it just pins it.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
Oh, that's what it meant, pin.
I was thinking it pinned this so it, like the coin, so it
didn't refresh.
Oh, okay.
This is a creditor coin.
Mine is 40!
That's a lot.
Okay, wow.
I'm gonna buy this prize.
It might be a mistake.
Oh, Oh, don't blame me.
Keep pushing.
Let's do some on this side.
Push these down.
Push these, yeah.
Push those bad boys here.
Also, I should be playing these.
I just realized.
I should be playing that.
Okay.
Okay, good.
We got weird.
Oh, good.
They're all, like, on one side, except this guy, but...
Okay.
I mean, I could do...
I feel like it's a waste, but, you know what?
Why not?
Oh, actually?
Maybe it's okay.
And then this is as...
Plus 15 value per round start.
So, like...
It's 34.
If I hold on to it...
And eventually play it, it would give a...
bunch of that like a bunch of
scoring points i guess oh we did it oh but i want to get
this guy out he's so close let's
see if we can push him out that'd be really funny because
then we could enter the shop with with only the 20 percent
up score okay so we like kind of yeah all right we're
learning everybody we're learning now I wonder if these
stack so if we have one and then we had a second one if we
could always play the second one you know what I mean and
have this one stack the score you get what I'm saying relic
coin still works in the clip I tried on my first one oh
really Let's try it.
Oh, it's separate per coin.
Well, just kidding.
Choco coin.
Three rounds later, weakens.
Well, what?
Oh, it's like a...
It's a britty...
Oh, it's for our little baker guy.
Star coin.
Place gadget.
UFO caller.
Every three items sold...
absorbs coins or drops they're so gosh this is so this is
getting this is getting crazy chocolate coin i'm kind of
hungry what time is that okay i have some time still before
dinner wait one second actually let me double check
i hate it when i get out of sync with the stream sorry what
is this one raccoon economics
hurts 1.5 score rate per remaining exchange what should I
get for dinner tonight guys what should I get for dinner
let's get another one I'm also oh wow this is like getting
pretty pricey now huh scary that sounds good we
probably should get some more chips huh 1.5 square rate per
remaining exchange current is nine okay ramen i probably
need something that i can get delivered i'm gonna have to
dust off door dash
bread pudding sounds so good all right We're gonna try this.
Economics.
Ooh, that was pricey.
Oh, probably because we still have this guy, huh?
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
We're gonna...
Oh!
Wait, that was so fast?
Wait, is it because of this?
The score rate?
Oh!
Wait, the score rate kind of goes hard, you guys.
Because we...
Wait, it kind of goes hard!
Whoa!
Bakugan!
Yeah, thanks to the new chip.
So this was a great, this was a great buy.
Also, it's a rare, I just noticed.
Interesting.
Okay, cool.
Let's go.
But we didn't get so many tickets.
So that's another thing, is sometimes playing is worth it to
get more tickets.
At round start, plus 8 value to coin and play oh uncommon
this is also unique what does a unique about it well I will
never know not the Bakugan badge all this math is making me
sleepy me too it's giving me a hungry tummy what is this one
oh the tick coin well we can get a Another cloverloin.
We can just keep stacking these.
Okay, that value is 49, and the other one is mysterious.
Got it.
Let's just keep trying.
Keep going for now.
Well, now it's 64.
And then you...
Slowly but surely, I feel I'm...
There's brainwaves happening.
You know?
Something's going on in an old noggin here.
Circus of value.
We're trying to get this guy out, though.
We don't want this bad coin anymore.
Exchange.
Okay, so it went down to nine.
Boo.
And then this one.
Oh, we also got to play.
Brain activity.
is
oh oh oh there he goes there he goes yeah oh oh yeah baby
she's thinking again chat brain blast
um ever ordered ramen ramen and skinny never tastes as good
to me when it's a No, I don't order ramen for that reason
too.
We cleared the bad coins!
My bad coins aren't bad enough.
Why are you trying to sabotage me, manager?
Dog food, autofill has no limit on the number of uses.
What is autofill?
Owner's tail, plus one coin in the shop.
Angry blowfish, the area of effects from prizes expanded.
Why are his tears so goopy?
Ew.
Manager, I think you have an infection.
Something that's not...
That ain't right.
Circus of value should be our stand-in for the G-word.
Let's go.
Circus of value.
Yeah.
Auto fill is when it drops coins because part of the field
is empty.
Ah.
I didn't realize it had a number of uses.
That kind of sounds good, though, right?
Hmm.
Let's try it.
What's this?
Next.
Copper coin will be silver coin.
After six coin inserted.
Circus of value.
I'm going to do horizontal so we can get different kinds of
coins?
What is this?
Fishbone.
Place gadget.
Fragile fishbone.
Physical barrier to influence coin movement?
Free to remove.
What?
Wait, that's crazy.
So you can manipulate the board.
This game is very interesting, everybody.
Give it a whirl.
Sure.
Let's Get the tick coin.
Hook up.
Whoa.
Don't eat it.
Don't eat what?
What am I eating?
Oh, this one.
The bad coin.
Lion coin.
Hunts the most valuable coins then disappears?
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Oh, I thought he was hunting.
Wait, is he?
Wait.
I'm not quite sure.
Err.
This scared me.
Okay.
Wait.
We gotta get rid of these guys.
Stag.
He's gonna eat my coins.
Actually, what are my...
What are my valuable coins?
I'm not quite sure.
Oh.
What if I...
Oh, I think that was a mistake.
Because now I can't push anything.
Well, I could.
It pushes around it.
Okay.
Wait, I want to see what happens.
How it works.
Oh, interesting.
I think I screwed myself over, though.
Game is officially horror.
Me coins!
Me de bloons!
It's funny, though, because I don't know if you guys can
tell, but I'm trying not to be, like, mega loud so that...
Because, you know, I'm obviously...
I'm not at home.
I'm in a hotel room, so.
I think I screwed myself over, though, for this.
Let's see.
Yeah, it's really...
Okay, we're going to get rid of it.
Feel free to remove.
Ah!
Alright.
Yeah, because of hotel.
Ugh.
Alright, I didn't want to exchange, but we gotta.
I also might want to throw out this relic coin.
Oh, wait, no.
We gotta get rid of the lions before we do that.
Yeah.
This guy.
Oh, there he goes!
That needs all prize balls in...
Oh, that doesn't really help me, though, huh?
Just kidding.
I have a prize ball.
UFO caller.
Let's do it.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, dang!
Okay.
That's what it meant.
What's this one?
Oh, but I didn't get it.
Okay.
Can you black hole some of the lions?
Let's try.
I think...
How many do I have?
Oh!
It worked!
I think I got rid of them.
Maybe?
Bonus time!
I think so.
This guy's gonna roll right in.
Come on.
I got it!
What does it do?
Absorb every three items sold.
Oh, that's right.
Okay.
Card puncher.
Oh, you cleared the bad coins.
Choose a keychain.
One chip slot.
Tool free re-rolls per shop visit.
Ooh.
Santa's portrait.
When you use a prize, 40% chance to spawn a prize ball in
the ain't taught.
Wait, that's kind of crazy.
Only listening to Mint Out of Context will have a sleep is
funny.
What do you guys think?
Chip slot is good.
We're not, we're not hungry for more right now though.
The two free re-rollers might be good, but hmm.
And that's every visit.
Hmm.
We'll do the re-rolls.
what is this bubble gum coin applies the giant modifier to
unmodified coins it touches let's draw it red packet coin
win scored five to 80 tickets and then we're gonna our bad
coin that's coming up is no prize can be used okay
round star plus three bars of spin energy oh wait does that
stack with our Economics.
Oh, wait, no.
Sorry, spin energy.
Sorry.
Just kidding.
I'm a stupid.
Plus six value per coin it touches.
Let's just buy all the new coins so we have them in our
arsenal.
You know?
I think we'll have to use this guy, though.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
And then I'm going to get this guy.
Before we expand.
so much because then I think he will stack right if we can
get more score rate I think we got to focus on that for for
winning this next round I think he isn't at home so she's a
ghost she's a ghost ambling or G ambling oh yeah let's roll
such oh greater coin giraffe coin that round start long neck
sweeps around twice oh it re-rolls everything each bankrupt
plus one score rate has remaining unused exchanges to
initial coin oh
wait but i already bought these i mean i could sell them but
let's just see oh this is Bullish coin.
Each conversion is plus two coin?
Okay.
I mean, ticket?
Tax doll.
Plus two ticket for each coin in selected area.
Neat.
Okay.
Piggy bag is good?
Oh, sorry.
I missed it.
I missed out.
All right.
Hoi!
Oh, it touched like one coin.
That's crazy.
I'm giant.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Wait, this is crazy.
And then, what if I do this?
Wait, plus six value.
This value is 64.
Wait, okay, hold on.
If I can get them to touch.
Every- it's a demo touch.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Maybe the value.
value is going.
Wait, the score is kind of insane actually.
Wait, if we can get the relic coin in, we will win.
We just got to get the relic coin in.
Push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push,
push, push, push, push, push, push, push.
Push, push, push, push, push, push, push.
Actually, we might win regardless.
Oh, we won regardless.
Wait, don't do it, don't do it, don't do it, don't do it,
don't do it, don't do it, don't do it, don't do it, don't do
it, don't do it, don't do it, don't do it, don't do it,
don't do it,
don't do it, don't do it, don't do it, don't do it,
don't do it, like, types of coins, you know.
Oh, what's this one?
Greater coin.
Scores nearby coins with higher value.
Oh, interesting.
Tax doll on the tower?
You're so right.
Oh my gosh, you're a genius.
You're a genius.
I exchange eight, plus eight to sell price of coins and
clip, but exchange costs.
One exchange.
exchange but we don't want to exchange so much right because
right now we're doing limited exchange
post are not worth unless you're unless you're selling a lot
of coins yeah yeah right let's reroll soap oh just just
kidding that's glue sticks to coins it touches and plus
eight to them.
Wait, that sounds fun.
An eyeball.
Sensoroin.
Amidst a laser to score the highest value coin and...
Cookie?
Redemption.
Wait.
I gotta look at like what ones are common and uncommon.
I don't sell so much, so I am gonna sell this one.
And then we're gonna buy it back.
Yeah.
When bankrupt, 20...
Okay.
Something is destroyed.
What is this?
Coin-Ninky!
Wait, could there be...
A coin-Ninky?
Cookies like last chance.
Okay, okay.
Coin-Ninky!
Let's try.
Let's keep going.
Holy!
Oh wait, wait, wait, wait!
Tax doll!
Yes!
What was this one?
Oh, sticks.
Alright.
Yes, keep going.
Yes, keep pushing.
Slowly but surely.
Yes!
The stack!
the stack huge stacks huge
stacks huge stacks no please oh I'm out what does that right
whoa we got another ball I think oh dang so it emits a laser
to and coins in its path.
Now, what does the path look like?
You know what I mean?
Switch coin.
It won't let me.
That sucks.
Exchange.
What do we got here?
Black hole, black hole.
Isn't this black hole?
Tax doll.
Another one.
Hmm.
Straight line.
Like, it's like forward because...
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I'm blocked.
You guys can't see it.
Here, I'll shrink down a little bit.
Here, I'll show you what I mean.
And then I'll move back over.
But...
See, it's like...
It's literally right there on the edge.
If it's...
If I use it and it's like a straight line, then it's
completely useless to me, you know what I mean?
So...
It goes from the coin to the top one.
Oh, so wherever this lands, it'll be like...
Wait, that's huge then!
Hold on.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna time this.
Wait, watch this.
Phew!
Oh.
Well, we still got an auto through.
That's not bad.
That works.
That works, I suppose.
Uh.
Interesting.
Let's see.
We still need 3,000, though.
And our score rate is only going to go down, so...
Desperate times.
Call for desperate measures.
Okay.
Fill her up.
Why did you do that?
Why did you go all the way over there?
Coin!
Reign of coins!
Oh, I do gotta exchange though.
But we're about to...
Okay.
We're not gonna be able to make the next round if we
don't...
If I don't change my strategy or something.
You know.
Coins.
Reign of coins.
At least I got some prizes.
No, no, no, wait.
Oh, I didn't count the next.
Oh, I tried to use it.
So I could get both of them.
Dang it.
I missed out on the one.
I was too slow.
Oh, next round is the bad coin.
While in play, no prizes can be used.
So we can't use the tax doll.
Oh, epic.
Set coins in selected areas.
It's a value of the most valuable coin in it.
I wish we could grab that.
Plus three tickets to sale price of all coins in Clip.
Mm-hmm.
Plus once...
Yeah, we'll do that.
Wait, is this...
It said in play.
At round start.
I'm gonna reroll.
I want that giant one again.
Okay.
yeah i do have a lot of tickets we can honestly well yeah
maybe we do need to expand them i'm being too like
conservative with my tickets i'm like i gotta hoard it all i
gotta hoard them let's see uh where's our ticket run where
it's like the more tickets you have the higher your score
rate is you know
i just oh what's so in what the hello oh there we go sorry
what's interesting is like you also have to strategize your
clip expansion because you only get six slots so it's just
like if you want more of the same coin like stacked versus
different coins oh it's so interesting
hmm clip expansion sounds like something from JJK
Oh, Mask Doll Unlocked.
20 types of coins.
Let's re-roll, we got it.
Hoi.
Enabling your rambling addiction.
Priceless.
No!
It's not, it's not the G word!
It's, um...
What did we say it was?
I don't remember.
I can't remember.
Grambling.
I can't say the G word or YouTube will like knock out my
channel.
Circus of...
Oh, the Circus of Halley, that's right.
What was this one?
On exchange.
I'm gonna reroll one more time.
We can't use items, so...
Uh...
Maybe a bunny coin would be good to...
Oh, a bunny coin would have been awesome if we had...
Hmm.
The tower.
Now one thing is, it says wall in play.
I'm assuming that does not mean on the clip, right?
That means like...
on the field yeah for this next one we won't be able to use
items because of the lock coin that is our bad coin but look
we're already at 9 out of 15 that's not bad it's not bad on
the pusher okay yeah yeah okay all right
I feel like it should buy a chip some kind of chip
after six inserted we'll do it the ticket whip we'll get
more tickets which I guess actually how does it help us
let's try the bunny let's go let's just go for it yeah yeah
hoi hoi oh oops oh Hoi!
When in play, plus one score rate.
And...
On exchange.
Scores nearby coins with higher value.
Hoi!
I wonder what the value of these is.
What did I get?
A rain?
Okay.
Oh.
Alright.
There's one lock.
How many are there?
Three?
Oh geez, that one's gonna be tough.
I
can't use it
20,000 yikes Okay Let's go G word hoi We're almost Close to
lock coin One There he goes, he's going, he's going down
Yeah Wait I got another bullish coin Did I buy two?
I don't remember buying, too.
What's this one?
Oh my gosh.
One drive, please.
No thank you.
Yeah, bunny coin.
I thought it would spawn another one.
I was mistaken.
We need to get this guy out of here.
We're exchanging.
Okay.
oh i don't know guys it's it's it's probably not gonna
happen i might have to pull out every stop we've got you
know especially because our uh score rate is gonna go mega
down in a bit
oh all right keep pushing these guys Look, there's the two
left.
Once we...
Once we get them, though, we can use items.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, so close, so close, so close, so
close.
So close, so close.
We're exchanging.
You never know.
We are almost halfway there, which is huge.
Oh!
wait was that it I think we just cleared them I think we
just cleared them yeah oh nice okay rain of clover oin oh
okay wait but this could be huge because then okay now the
values are bigger no we're exchanging wait what's this guy
this detonates all prize balls I have none plus two tickets
and like here 54 nice we're gonna try and get this relic
coin I gotta keep exchanging circus of values sure thing
looks like you're jambling no no I feel like that's too
close.
Maybe now?
Guys, I don't think this is it.
I don't think this is it.
I don't think so.
I think it's over for us.
We'll have to shake the machine.
We're gonna have to shake the machine.
What did I get?
Eight more coins.
What's this one?
We got like halfway there.
Oh, thanks for the autofill, I guess.
Thank you.
Ah!
Oh, there we go.
I didn't realize I still had... Sometimes I don't realize I
still have some in my hand.
Come on.
We have no more exchanges.
42 oh we got the tower
wait is that really it just like starts stacking like that
that's so funny
not even that not even oh if only we had our score rate the
circus is not valuing everybody wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
she's going rambling she's jeering i don't i still don't
think so though i still don't think so well that was a great
combo though isn't it oh wait i have some in my hand i just
realized we got more bonus coins no don't rain
guys oh seven Shake the machine.
Even if I shake the machine, will that even do anything?
Good thing we got the dog food.
Holy cow.
Saucer.
They gave me two measly coins.
It's all over.
Oh!
Thank you so much for the return rate.
Griffin!
Thank you!
I obtained something.
What is this, dear?
Absorbs coins.
Is this garlic?
I need to strongly shake the cabinet.
I feel like...
You know what?
There is a speed up, right?
I'm out of...
Oh.
Racing glitches!
Thank you for something!
Thank you, Ducky, thank you!
CC, thank you!
Thanks for all the gifted memberships.
Thank you.
Well, shoot.
We got it to nine, round nine.
Good job, Teen Darko!
Thank you!
Ahab, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Creditoin.
Wait, value times debt.
At round start, debt plus 50.
15% wins, scored, lose, tickets equal to debt.
Okay.
Yo-yo.
Coins gain plus 16 value when a prize ball lands nearby.
Rich doll.
Mask doll.
Converts coins into a selected area and random coins of the
same rarity.
Consumes 20% of ticket balance.
Coins in selected areas gain value equal to the tickets.
Oh.
See, that's where you got to, like, stack your tickets.
tickets right silver card plus 25 conversion rate coin sold
in shop minus one and we got a new character biologist every
hunt has a 50 chance to spawn is that poo a poo coin
fertilizes more coins and then destroyed on exchange you can
get an extra animal coin holy cow
Phil thank you so much thank you for the gift and Draco's
thank you for the time you did now well thank you thank you
guys for all the gifted thank you so so much thank you thank
you the poo poo coin the pee poo coin the peepaw coin good
progress if I had to
games of like this and Clover Pit.
I still think I like Clover Pit a little bit more.
I think this game is fun but definitely it requires much
more concentration.
There's like a lot going on you know.
I came in at a good time.
It requires like so much like
it doesn't have quite the rush of the slots because it's a
slow pusher yeah it requires a lot of planning a lot of like
one thing that I like about Clover Pit is you know the slots
are a good RNG and this is RNG as well but at the same time
I have to like be like okay where am I strategizing my coins
Yeah, which is not a bad thing.
But my brain is so small.
My brain is so small.
But it was really satisfying watching them get pushed in,
I'll be honest.
Yeah, the big flashy numbers.
We got the towers, though.
That was pretty fun.
I'm sorry that today is a little bit of a shorter stream.
But I'm going to go eat.
eat because i'm hungry um i haven't eaten i don't know i
gotta go possess someone's stat i'm gonna turn i'm gonna
turn into just a puddle of ectoplasm no energy but thank you
guys for i wanted to at least try this so i'm glad i kind of
like got like a little bit of a sample um of it at the very
least yeah thanks guys for hanging out with me as always and
yeah I won't be streaming for the next couple of days I'll
miss you guys but then I'll be back on Monday Monday Monday
I'll be back to stream yes yes yes Monday Monday so I'll see
you Monday hopefully if not and if you're watching the bod
I'll see you when I see you next there's a simple one-click
called Scritchy Scratchy.
Wait, what is that?
Scritchy Scratchy.
I'm looking it up.
Scritchy.
Oh.
Scritchy Scratchy.
Wait, is this like...
What is this?
Is this like a...
Like a...
Scratch...
Scratch off?
Oh, no.
Wait.
That looks really satisfying.
When I was a wee ghost, my grandpa would give me the
scratches and be like, scratch them off, Minto.
You're my lucky charm.
Okay, but I'm going to miss you the whole time, do you?
Or no deal.
Thank you, haunted bakery.
You're welcome.
Wait, why am I...
Bye, Minto.
bye bye bye bye bye um scratch card game yeah there we go
thank you yeah thank you so much i'll miss you guys i'll
miss you guys how much did you win if i won like 10 bucks my
grandpa would take me out for ice cream
maybe we'll play the scritchy scratchy then oh my gosh it
will scratch that my little brain itch maybe the job
interview curse wish curse holds true me until i got this
job offer as well corinne congrats yeah yeah yippee
congratulations yeah if you have you can use my luck for
your gotcha everybody or your um your scritchy scratchies
your wait let me add this to my not no add to where's the
wish list oh add to my wish list service okay thank you guys
so much for watching thanks for hanging out with me for even
just a little bit i really appreciate it all oh oh this
weekend is weebcon if i see you tomorrow at the concert or
the meet and greet on sunday then um uh weebcon i'll see you
there maybe if not then we shall meet we'll meet again don't
know where don't know where but i know we will probably be
on made mint channel um uh remember young kids fellow kids
not to use the G would or else your channel will be
terminated we'll meet again unless my channel's terminated
because I
love rambling I love rambling I love rambling with a G I
love rambling with a G I love rambling with a G you can't
you can't silence me YouTube I love rambling with a G I love
rambling with a G, I love rambling with a G, I love rambling
with a G.
I'm gonna say it loud and proud.
I love.